you
thomas heatherwick represent this prep
this expansion of design even further
from the grocer's definition of design
much broader
and you are pushing it even further
in your work but also in your thinking
where do you think the next frontiers
lie
i suppose i i genuinely don't feel that
i'm
pushing boundaries i'm just trying to
not get stuck in the
some funny quirk of this time you just
walk down the street
and just you start seeing problems you
just think why is that so bad
why is that so bad why did that well and
so
for me everything grows from problems
and and to me i see a problem not as a
negative thing but as an incredibly
inspiring thing it's i think the only
time you stop having ideas is if you
think the world's perfect
in terms of what's next i mean there are
we're just surrounded by things that
could be better
my particular interest is in
uh more and more is in our
is in the public realm is how we all
come together
and the parts there are the obvious
parts of the public realm around us
and i think file find that love keeps
being placed on the obvious bits
instead of the unobvious bits and it's
kind of a cliche of cities that the most
artistic buildings are the arts
buildings
but they're the buildings that not
everyone goes into and not everyone has
to go into or needs to go into
the and they're full of interesting
fascinating things already
and so but the the places when you think
of what's the worst part
of a city and you think they're they're
probably
in the health care systems in education
systems
justice system and and in
local government and the
i think that that for me i'm motivated
by
where you can make the biggest
difference